[Music]
on this monday night holiday plans
upended by omicron with an explosion of
cases expected soon quebec is reimposing
restrictions right now as a business
owner it's depressing it sucks and the
rush for rapid tests now they're going
through the hunger games rapid test
edition fresh fears for long-term care
homes we still don't have a fully
boosted population of residents and
staff from vaccine boosters to omicron
symptoms we're putting your covid
questions straight to the experts
a critical bc artery gets the green
light the reopening and the relief
plus rebuilding an ancient roman city
and we don't know how it looked like how
pompei's ruins are being reconstructed
by a robot
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff
semple evening and thank you for joining
us provinces are scrambling tonight to
reimpose restrictions with covet 19
cases climbing to new heights driven in
part by that highly transmissible
omicron variant nationally quebec is the
hot spot hitting a new single day record
with more than 4 500 cases reported
today most of those infections are in
people who are double vaccinated the
province is also seeing a jump in
hospitalizations up 21 today with three
more deaths reported the quebec
government is taking drastic action
tonight imposing new widespread
restrictions quebec's health minister
says the situation is critical
i know the situation is tough
but now is the time again
not to get discouraged to be strong
i ask everyone to be part of the effort
again
it can make all the difference
quebec is not the only province taking
steps to try to slow the spread of
omicron mike drolet has more on canada's
fight to contain the new variant in our
top story tonight
quebecers have been down the restriction
road before they know it's a bumpy ride
but changing the rules mere hours after
they went into effect the province's top
health officials seemed as stunned as
everyone else as we say in france du
james
this this is unbelievable the new
measures include a mandatory work from
home order for offices bars casinos
theaters and gyms will be closed and
restaurants can only open between 5 and
10 p.m with reduced capacity the owners
of this montreal restaurant saw the
writing on the wall and shut down
yesterday they feared it was only a
matter of time before someone on their
staff got infected as a business owner
it's depressing
it sucks there's nothing we can do about
it all we can think of is the safety of
our staff the safety of our children
quebec has been hardest hit by the
omicron variant but can the rest of the
country be far behind ontario bc and
newfoundland have put some measures in
place limiting indoor capacity in
restaurants and bars and applying
footloose rules to big parties meaning
no singing and dancing in toronto
residents had already begun limiting
numbers for dinner two it was going to
be about 15 and then we canceled it
ontario saw long frustrated lines of
people waiting for booster shots after
they were made available to anyone 18
and older just days after exhausting a
large supply of free antigen tests in
only a few hours most everybody it
appears is desperate to avoid another
lockdown even though doctors say we
haven't hit omicron's peak based on what
we're seeing in europe there will be a
large number of cases over the next two
to three weeks and what happens next may
depend less on numbers and more on the
ability of hospital icus to keep up
microlite global news toronto
canada's minister of foreign affairs has
tested positive for covid19 melanie
jolie made the announcement on twitter
saying she's in isolation after getting
a rapid test result she says he's now
awaiting the result of a pcr test jolie
is encouraging canadians to limit
contacts and follow public health
guidelines
soaring cases have sparked a rush across
canada for those rapid antigen tests
many people are hoping the self-test
kits can provide an extra layer of
security to help keep their families
safe especially over the holidays but as
michael couture explains those rules and
recommendations for rapid tests depend
on where you live
day one of the rollout of rapid tests in
quebec started early and ended just as
quickly people lined up in the freezing
cold just to get their hands on a pack
of five smeta didn't feel me pokemon i
was expecting a lineup but not like this
said this woman minutes later relief
from another customer
distribution sites have been set up
across ontario with similar scenes this
line snaking around union station in
toronto underscoring the scarcity of
supplies the people of ontario have
already gone through the hunger games
vaccine edition and now they're going
through the hunger games rapid test
edition it's simply not fair meanwhile
in bc rapid antigen tests still aren't
widely available to the public and it's
frustrating some frontline healthcare
workers we have been sitting on these
tests here in british columbia for over
a year now and i do not understand why
now we are in a bit of a panic and the
public is just asking for these why we
haven't been more proactive the
frustration is coupled with confusion
over when to use a rapid antigen test
quebecers are being told to use one if
they have coveted 19 symptoms but in
ontario you're supposed to use one if
you don't have symptoms appreciating
that we're in the middle of a pandemic
the omicron wave things are dynamic
they're changing all the time but crisp
clear communication is what canadians
need right now
while a spike in cases of the omicron
variant have caused a run on rapid tests
across the country public health experts
warn they are not the gold standard pcr
test
adding masking and social distancing
remain important a negative rapid test
can't be used as a license to go out and
be reckless and disregard all public
health measures but if we use them in
conjunction with everything else they
can be very useful and they can help
especially if people want that extra
peace of mind over the holidays
mike lacouter global news ottawa
the emergence of omicron is forcing many
canadians to rethink their holiday plans
difficult decisions over whether to
visit friends and family are even more
poignant for people with loved ones in
long-term care as jamie morocco explains
the climbing covid caseload is prompting
a familiar warning
there are some signs it's christmas but
paul hartford isn't in the holiday mood
he lost his brother and had to put his
father leo into long-term care now
thanks to covid he says this could be
the first year in 71 years his parents
spend the holidays apart i don't know
what
signing my father out to take him to the
farm to visit my mom and my
sister-in-law i don't know if that's
going to be allowed
and if it is i don't know what that
looks like in the face of the highly
contagious omicron ontario restricted
long-term care residents from going on
overnights provinces were forced to move
quickly to limit the number of visitors
and some even put mandatory vaccine
rules in place precautions experts say
we need because we didn't get boosters
into arms quickly enough i'm actually
very terrified about what's facing our
long-term care facilities and really the
you know the major fear is that so many
of the frontline staff have not received
their third doses 86 percent of
long-term care residents in ontario are
vaccinated but just 37 percent of staff
have their third dose doctors say the
rates are likely similar country wide
just imagine you have an outbreak staff
have to isolate we don't have enough
staff to to replace them
all of a sudden it's not just about the
risk of of dying from covid but we know
that when you don't have enough staff to
even provide the basic care that people
need that's when everything starts to
fall apart during the pandemics first
wave some seniors were left alone in
their rooms with devastating outcomes
advocates say isolation isn't just
dangerous for physical health but
residents mental health too it was the
most devastating thing could have
possibly happened for
vulnerable lonely seniors they're
isolated in their rooms all meals in
rooms it's part of the reason debbie
marsden will be taking her mother home
for the holidays we don't know when
we'll be able to return them because of
the restrictions so we're taking a risk
paul understands the need for
restrictions he worked in health and
safety for decades still it hurts him to
know how much his mother will miss her
husband i hate seeing her pain
and
that's the hardest part for me
is seeing her pain torn between keeping
everyone safe and bringing them together
when they aren't certain how many
holidays are left jamie morocco global
news toronto
to other news now and the federal
government has announced a 28 million
dollar plan to help pei potato farmers
who've been hit by a trade suspension
with the united states
beside facilitating additional
processing this funding will be used to
support the diversion of surplus
potatoes by redirecting surplus potatoes
to food banks and other food aid
organizations
the agriculture minister also said the
money will help cover the cost of
disposing of the remaining crop in an
eco-friendly way exports of fresh pei
potatoes to the u.s were halted last
month after the discovery of a potato
wart in the province it was first
located in two fields back in october
the trade suspension has cost farmers
millions in lost revenue
to some much needed good news now in
british columbia the coquihalla highway
finally reopened to commercial traffic
today weeks after extreme weather
destroyed parts of the pivotal route
with floods and landslides crews are
still busy repairing the critical
connection but news of its reopening is
welcome relief to truckers and bc's
supply chain global's john hua is on the
coquihalla near hope bc tonight john
well jeff it's pretty remarkable to
think that just over a month ago the
coquihalla highway was literally torn to
pieces in 20 different places now you
can still see evidence on one side of me
where both lanes were washed out and are
being rebuilt as we speak
but on the other side commercial traffic
is once again moving freely on this
crucial supply route that connects bc
with the rest of the country
many drivers know it as british
columbia's highway through hell so
hopefully we don't have to chain up
now truckers are calling the coca-cola
a beacon of hope
i'm kind of excited for it to be open i
didn't know it was going to open so soon
i mean it's a main link you can't get
through without that one barely a month
after the 543 kilometer highway was
ripped apart in multiple places by
atmospheric rivers and flooding this
critical supply route connecting bc to
the rest of canada is open once again
the only thing that could bring the
coca-cola back
was the sheer force of will
of the road building community for 31
days straight
round the clock to get this to happen
it didn't take long for important goods
and supplies to hit the reopened road
which normally sees on average 4 000
trucks a day you really can't overstate
the importance of the coquihalla in
terms of how it connects the lower
mainland and the port of vancouver and
all those those things that we take for
granted to the rest of the country
for truck driver len kimmer is seeing
the patrick fixes first hand offering
hope for a province trying to rebuild
making everything a little safer and
everything move a little better
all the good now bc's ministry of
transportation reiterated the fact that
this is not the old coquihalla highway
and these are just temporary fixes
when it comes to building the highway
back better including climate
adaptations or the work to figure out
those overall costs and timelines has
only just begun jeff
john wall reporting near hope bc thanks
john
a chinese tennis star speaks out coming
up what pung shui is saying about that
sexual assault allegation leveled at a
high-ranking chinese official
plus the aftermath of a devastating
storm in the philippines
well there is grim news tonight out of
the philippines the number of people
confirmed killed by a powerful storm has
jumped to more than 375
super typhoon rye hit the country last
thursday officials describing the
aftermath as complete carnage
international charities are now
appealing for donations to help with
urgent relief efforts
chinese tennis star punxsui says a
social media post that appeared to
include an allegation of sexual assault
was misunderstood last month shwai
appeared to accuse a high-ranking
chinese politician of sexually
assaulting her in the past following her
post she wasn't seen in public for
nearly three weeks prompting concerns
about her safety in an interview with a
media outlet in singapore the 35 year
old now says she was not harmed and that
she's been living at home in beijing the
women's tennis association is still
calling for a full transparent
investigation
canada is among several countries
expressing grave concern over the
results of this weekend's election in
hong kong because of new rules imposed
by china only pro-beijing candidates
were allowed to run for government that
resulted in a turnout of just 30 percent
the lowest since the british handed hong
kong over to china in 1997. in a joint
statement canada and four other
countries say the changes have
undermined the territories rights while
eroding the democratic process
from symptoms to spread we're answering
your questions about covid19 omicron and
the holidays next
[Music]
welcome back moderna says its booster
shot appears to significantly increase
protection against the omicron variant
the pharmaceutical company says an
additional half dose of its vaccine saw
a 37-fold increase in antibody levels a
full dose led to an 83-fold increase
both produced side effects comparable to
those seen after the first two doses now
these lab results are preliminary and
will now undergo a full scientific
review
the omicron variant and the prospect of
another covid christmas are prompting
plenty of questions from viewers to
answer some of those we are joined now
by dr anna banerjee who's an infectious
disease specialist with the university
of toronto dr banerjee thanks so much
for joining us you know we've heard that
news about moderna and the effectiveness
of its booster shot so the first
question for you comes from erna jean
who says that my first two vaccinations
were astrazeneca then she had the pfizer
shot six months later does it matter
what booster shots she receives
so basically i consider
pfizer and modern-like crest and colgate
they're basically the same the the
buffers are slightly different but they
work in the same way so right now
either of the messenger rna vaccines are
fine
okay next question comes from dale who
says that the vaccines that we're
currently using are for the earlier
covid variants of course that's what
they were designed for initially but now
we have a new variant do we need to
start trying to make a new vaccine
altogether
i think that there's some controversy i
mean if you listen to dr fauci in the
states he'll say you know it seems to
work and recently the booster as you
said for moderna seems to cause a good
immune response but some of us are
wondering you know if the vaccine was
designed for the original alpha variant
maybe it's time to uh
to to look at updating the vaccine
especially if it looks like you know
with two shots the the effectiveness is
going down until you get boosted so i i
think that's a question that we'll have
in the future
especially as as mutations occur like
the influenza vaccine maybe it needs to
be updated
yeah and we have heard of course from
moderna and pfizer both with plans to
develop new vaccines to better match the
omicron variant if needed next question
for you comes from karen who asks what
are the symptoms you feel if you test
positive for the omicron variant
well it depends it depends on many
different things uh it depends on how
old you are what your immune status is
like if you've been unvaccinated or not
from what i understand omicron is
similar to delta
and so you can have symptoms for all the
way from no symptoms just a mild
mild runny nose cold like symptoms all
the way to more serious symptoms the
more serious symptoms are
you know if someone's not vaccinated or
someone's compromised and so they
couldn't uh you know take the vaccine as
well so it really depends on on on many
circumstances
okay next question comes from pat asking
about transmissibility so wondering if
the omicron variant is more
transmissible when we touch surfaces for
example or is it mostly airborne spread
what do you think
so there's been some controversy over
this over the years and i've thought
almost from the very beginning that
co-fed was airborne and now more and
more people are saying that it's
airborne so it's really not uh you know
touching surfaces even though you can
get
viruses that way
through droplet spread if someone's
coughing or sneezing
but a lot of people are saying that's
really through these small particles
that linger in the air for a while and
so
and that might impact
you know ventilation systems the kind of
mask we wear but i think that we're
thinking that it's it's uh
more airborne than from touch last year
people worried about grocery bags and
shopping carts and i really think it's
it's more the the air that we're
concerned about dr anna banerjee an
infectious disease specialist from the
university of toronto thanks so much for
tackling some of those questions for us
really appreciate it my pleasure thank
you
and we will be putting questions about
omicron straight to the experts all week
so please send us yours to your
questions at globalnews.ca
next the robots repairing history at the
site of an infamous volcanic disaster
many families will spend part of their
holidays crouching over jigsaw puzzles
working to piece together a bigger
picture well that activity is a
year-round occupation for archaeologists
whose job can involve painstakingly
reassembling ancient ruins and artwork
in italy researchers have come up with a
new way to reconstruct ancient ruins
redmond shannon explains
the eruption of mount vesuvius in 79 a.d
was both horrific and historic it froze
the city of pompeii in time until
excavations began in the 1700s
since then many of the ruins and
colorful frescoes have crumbled thanks
to careless excavations rainfall clumsy
tourists and even second world war
bombings putting them back together is
hugely time consuming it also doesn't
increase the knowledge
or the understanding or the expertise
over the archaeologists of the
conservators is just putting the pieces
together the real work for the
archaeologist comes after that so
researchers in italy are planning to 3d
scan every single piece of some frescoes
and use artificial intelligence and
robots to put them back together we have
also to take into consideration there
could be parts of the drawing that is
over the fresco that are not visible
easily so we will use this type of
technology to investigate what could be
could have been there in 2010 the
gladiators barracks collapsed photos can
be used like the cover of a jigsaw
puzzle box to help with reconstruction
but with the so-called house of the
lovers hit by allied bombs in 1943 ai
will have to work harder because we do
not have the the box and we don't know
how it looked like in the past
the project aims to help everyone in
archaeology focus on research instead of
puzzle solving but if our system works
then we can export that technology and
we will be able to
reconstruct frescoes that nowadays are
just stored into store rooms the project
is expected to take four years but
that's only the blink of an eye for
patient historians redmond shannon
global news london
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm jeff semple tonight's
year canada is this month's big truck
parade in downtown campbell river bc we
love seeing your canada so please keep
sending us your festive photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you back here again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]